all right well we took a break after the
bridge now we're going to go do uh fence
we're going to repair fence so I like to
get the fences done every now and then
so the animals don't uh scratch their
eyes so gatlin's getting his driver's
license right now hey hello so same
Principle as a big vehicle but slightly
different uh you got to hold in the
brake when you turn the key all
right all
right there you go you can let off now
so it's got a clutch that's on a belt so
it doesn't roll like a car wheel but you
notice it's in gear right now so uh just
drive out underneath this tree there's
no seat belts okay there no seat belts
for said there's a clutch or no clutch
no nothing you just as you press the gas
the uh belt will will compress the
clutch is automatic and it'll Lurch
forward but then
dry you got it
yep keep going you'll want to go right
in between the tree and the
trailer and what you'll do is uh as soon
as you get the driveway you'll turn and
go up that way right yeah and we'll go
we start following the fence we're going
to pull down all that electric old
electric wire we're going to get rid of
those yellow insulators and then
anything that's broken we go ahead and
take care of as well there things like
that you can just drive right through it
it won't
matter this as fast as it goes no it
it'll do 70 but I put a regulator on it
so to keep it under 20 but once you get
out there you could go you know once you
get straight and through the gate just
floor it and you'll see
[Music]
W yeah it's got a little pick them up
juice then we'll just go down to the
gate and we'll start there what you're
looking for is the broken wires so when
you see a broken wire you can just take
your foot off the gas it's got a brake
clutch all right uh but if you need a
hard stop you can use the brake but
usually it'll Coast Coast to a stop and
then any of those yellow things we're
going to pull those off the p uh off the
pipes too right those used to be an old
insulator all this old scraps of wire
that I've been pulling out of the ground
we're going to throw in the bed at back
of this thing and just clean it up so
the animals don't get hurt and fix the
brakes there's yeah there's a brake all
right
perfect turn the key you can turn it
off and those yellow things are super
hard to get off the uh pipes I mean I
just all I do is just torque at them and
see I like that one I I don't know if I
left it or
not but I'm trying to clean up you know
what I mean like I don't want to leave a
bunch
of you know that I hit play yeah I did
um
record just walk down and Gatlin and
just you know anywhere we see these but
I'll teach you to do this right now
there's a lot of ways of doing wire this
is the way I don't like to do it whoever
fixed it last
time but it's the way most ranchers tell
you is right but I don't like to do that
so see what happened is the Bulls came
through here fighting yeah and they
broke it and so a lot of people will
crimp a crimp repair in here I don't
think that lasts so um I'll get my
gloves and show you how I do it all
right so what I do you know obviously
the crimp I'll cut that
off so what I do is I unravel the um The
Wire yeah back about 6 in 8 in
in and then I braid in the uh the
solution that way I'm not buying
anything I'm just using what wire is
there so you know I just unravel
it and then if I can grab the other side
I'll just wave it in but sometimes I can
right so see how this is all broken so
I'll have to pull this staple
out first time well I have a better
video on this uh this without me
blocking it right here I'm just teaching
Gatlin how to do this so uh you know his
presentation's for him but basically I
spay those two pieces of wire apart then
I braid one strand over it and the other
strand over that in opposite directions
one clockwise one
counterclockwise I do that on both ends
then I don't need any extra grommets I
don't need ferals I don't need special
expensive CRI crimping devices and I
find if I pull this tight uh it spreads
the load out over a longer surface area
so you can pull them a little bit tight
now I'm careful not to tighten these too
much these old strands cuz you break
them but that's what I'm doing I'm just
weaving two kinds of Bob wire
together it's already got you whoopsie
did not see that I was too focused on
here bar wire it really does have a mind
of its own
[Music]
all right you want to grab it like right
there and just put a little tension look
down the line make sure I you know that
it's not real
floppy I'll do the same over here a help
here he's pulling the tension in the
line so that it's a a little tighter now
I could have a fence stretcher do this
with a fence stretcher I've got one but
I find setting it up and getting it to
hold on with these old strands and not
going too tight breaking them uh just a
human touch seems to make do and later
on I'll show you how I tighten them
anyway but uh so he's he's holding on to
it with the pliers and giving me a
little tension there so the line doesn't
just flop down but I just twist these by
hand all together I leave the little end
up like a barb wire that's all I do on
it so nothing fancy uh but I am teaching
Gatlin here he's picking up pretty fast
he's a a quick learner he's a young man
he's not a late teen he's an early teen
kid just heading into getting his
driver's permit so uh there'll be
opportunity I'm going to let them drive
a little bit more the more you let kids
drive the safer the world is for them
and the happier we all are so I'm happy
to have him here he's he's driving
around today I'm not driving nothing but
there's that strand all mended up you
hardly even notice all right now this is
uh this is how I pull it tight if I need
to
so once you you find the post is where
you do it well after you do the post if
you give them a little crimp like that
Ben they'll do that so uh let me get the
hammer and a
staple would you grab the and uh the
split in there and just pull it uh tight
for me SPL yeah just grab it here and
just lean against it
all right and let's do it the opposite
direction we grab it this way and pull
the fence that way
okay oh over here on this side got
one and then when I want to make them
tight what I do uh from this point on is
uh I told all the slack into this spot I
physically just kind
of you know drive a nail into it against
the post right so um in fact you could
do that that one that's good I dropped
the staple somewhere in here hope I lost
it
huh well Gone
Forever it's really hard to drive those
Staples so it's good practice for you uh
go uh running and it ran into a piece of
the barb wire dangling like this and the
barb wire went right through its eye
into its brain killed it instantly Oh e
yeah it was
terrible you see that once it sticks
with you how dangerous bad fence is you
know
yeah and uh for me it was in Michigan
middle of winter so I couldn't even bury
the thing I had this Dead Goat that I
had figure out what to do well I've got
a playful nature so I gave uh Gatlin
here the hardest of uh of jobs to do
keep tension on a wire driving a staple
listen I don't even know if he's ever
picked up a hammer before he showed up
out to the farm I did not ask him for
his extensive resume this is a boy's
first job and when you hire a young man
your job is to help him and they're not
ready for a eight hour day they're not
ready to be yelled at they're not ready
to do a lot of things and we forget as
we get older what it was like for us
when we had our first job and hopefully
we had a good good boss a good teacher I
had good ranchers they're all kindly a
little ory and so I'm a little ory to
this young man I tease him a smidgen and
all in good fun letting them know but
this is the hard job and if you'll
notice there I'm using a hatchet Hammer
uh so you got that sharp edge to
intimidate you uh on top of it but
driving these staples in if you've never
driven a staple into a fence you have no
idea how how hard this is so I let this
run with uh with Gatlin uh regular speed
so you can
appreciate his struggle now I'm watching
them out of the corner of the eye while
I'm uh fixing fence down down the way
I'm I'm wiring all the fence there is
dozens and dozens and dozens of the wire
straps out so I'm I'm fixing all them as
I'm going L do this every spring not hes
in the
fence I told you it's hard isn't it it's
hard to get the right the right angle
it's really hard he's still he's still
working on that staple I'm trying to get
it in there without one hurting
myself
to No it's it's hard get in there it's
surprisingly
hard well can you uh hold this area over
here like pull on it a little
bit so I can get more room to come on
right there I need
more you want me to do this one yeah my
friend I can't I can't get the right
angle no I I set you up on that one it
really is hard to
do you're going to do it in half the
time no I will well I'll do it but I
won't do it in half the
time yeah there you
go anyway that's how I pull them tight
all right after the fact as I physically
do that I'll get it next time yeah what
next time yeah yeah I set you
woo but uh and then as far as uh see
where it's kind of floppy yeah so what I
do is I go down see how and I give them
all a little
crmp and you don't even notice
it but's see how it draws that right
up so that's all you do is just give
them a little crimp as you walk down oh
hey this one's just straight on grab a
stretch staple to do this one all right
and that one won't be as hard for
you all right so what happens the fences
that messes it up well the Bulls come
through on each side and when they're
after each they just walk right through
like a spaghetti and then it breaks the
fence and then you have to put it back
together so that's what we're working on
right now plus you know the post can let
go of you know a little wear and tear as
normal but this is all bold damage
that's bull crap man while he learns to
do this and just know uh I know that he
is struggling and uh but I let him
struggle and that's all part two of of
the training listen I didn't hire a
30-year-old man here to help me run the
fence this boy this young man called me
and asked me for a job and when a when a
young man asks you for a job and you
need you got help you hire him and you
take the time to teach him and that's
your job as an older fella uh to do that
and uh it wasn't mama who asked or his
grandom or anything else it was this
young man trying to trying to make his
way in the world with the first job and
this is a heck of a first job let me
tell you I got so many things to do uh
the first video I Shot with him he was
uh doing the uh uh mud the
concrete found some sandburs I bet you
yep all
right almost looks good
[Music]
all right that was um actually about 50t
a really bad fence trans missing
retaining wires gone Staples
out there's the staple out let's go down
in the middle and I'll walk down and
drive that missing
staple you grab all them yellow
reflectors while I do that every one of
the little Gatlin found weird bugs I've
never seen them before I don't know what
they are I think they're beet sort a
beetle of some
kind well we are removing there you're
being evicted y'all getting evicted get
out from behind oh here's another torn
piece of f yeah so what I'll do is cut
that off and wrap it around and nail it
good catch but you see why uh they're
bad for the animals imagine you're
grazing a catle cow in the middle of the
night you get that in your eyeball take
a minute and remember the man that hired
you the first time and how were you and
if you're in farm country you might have
started working I don't know like me I
was bailing hay probably around 12 years
old but I had jobs before that mowing
the lawn things like that and I think I
made a a dime of baale throwing them up
on the uh the truck and I was a little
dude they they were 80 lbs just like
Gatlin here with the the mud yesterday
and doing all this work for me today but
you can see his value he's still cutting
my time in half uh with all of the uh we
ran down got all them reflectors all the
running he has value right now gatlin's
looking for the next broken strand so
many of these were missing their ties
that I decided to walk down let's
see already you found a broken strand
one right there on the bottom oh I see
it
yeah left over here on top on top these
bottom ones I'm just going to wrap
around try to make tight and wrap around
all
right this one's actually broken
twice what happens to these besides
being close to the ground is they get
caught by the mower decks you know and
then they get snapped
off yep good
eye once I can I'll try to fix ones like
this that are just all rusted away I
don't see any point in
it well not only were you responsible
for hiring them at first but they are
and uh what their experiences are but uh
let them use you as a reference so that
they getting not only P so I'm not
paying them as little as I can I'm
paying them a man's wage uh but also I I
want him to use me as a job reference
when you're a job reference for somebody
your job when somebody calls you isn't
to play The Devil's Advocate and to say
good and bad about uh the young man
you've helped your job is to uh prop him
up and uh you know anything that a young
man needs to learn he can learn on the
job but you're going to talk like here
where uh Gatlin is totally focused on
helping me he's there ahead of me quite
frequently that's the skill set that
you're after uh he's working hard he's
focused we're two hours into into
building here fenon fenon is the
boringest cutest hardest little job in
the entire world and it's Texas hot and
the gatlin's right there that's the kind
of things you say when somebody uses you
for a job reference for a young person
uh you focus on the strengths that
breaks to young people let them wander
around a little bit let them uh uh you
know give them a bit of time but also
when you're a job reference make sure
it's a solid reference or don't even
offer
so I mentioned earlier that Gatlin
called me asked me for that job well you
know I don't want a babysit somebody I
don't want their mama calling well let's
take a look now at Gatlin I'll run him
full speed at at the end of the day here
he is on a a post without my help
without my intervention and he is
doggedly determined on each one of these
posts sure he doesn't have a 240b man
swing like I do uh but I got you know 40
years of experience Beyond him him don't
expect people to be at your experience
level give them that Grace where they
can figure things out and give them the
time don't sit there over their shoulder
and helicopter them and micromanage
every post that Gatlin runs into he just
gets better at doing what he needs to do
for that particular job and uh you know
this is an hour and a half into him uh
driving uh post and I I enjoy hearing
him make man noises when he gets up off
the ground like uh ooh
he it cracks me up so then I don't feel
so so old having a young person around
is just as good for me as it is for him
to be around now I've got a couple other
fellas that come out that are in their
30s and then frons is as Elder he's
retired so them old Cowboys come out and
help me too uh but uh I so I say I'm a
solo Builder but the fact of the matter
is I could use a full-time young man
like Gatlin uh but uh I got to go pick
him up he doesn't have his driver's
license yet so why am I letting him
drive my stuff around uh one he can't
hurt anybody and uh two I got a uh
regulator on that uh UTV he could not go
70 miles an hour will he make mistakes
on it well I hope not uh but that is the
nature of being a kid you remember when
you were a kid and you treat kids better
than somebody misuse you you make sure
you don't misuse some other kid your job
is to help young men get off off the
ground and and be excited about work and
be excited about earning money don't
cheat them don't uh underpay them just
because you're training them too right
uh let them get excited it doesn't cost
you nothing out of your own pocket uh
anymore and looky here this young man
first day on a job um I'm telling you he
cut my workload in half in concrete when
he did that job yesterday he was a
full-sized man um and by the end of the
day he's a cowboy here uh each one of
these posts takes him 20 minutes but
tippity tap tippity tap he just stays at
it till he gets the job done and I you
saw me in the background I wired up
three four five other posts uh but uh I
didn't have to drive a single nail so
he's taking care of all that himself and
I'm really enjoying that we're getting
towards the end of this run and this one
run was a uh uh on both sides it's 3/10
of a mile so the full run is a little
over a half a mile of fencing and uh
I'll tell you what that'll wear you out
he stayed positive he stayed focused uh
you put your knee in sandburs and he
stepped in fire ants Texas is mean y'all
and to have a young man out there
helping me uh really made me happy uh
the whole day went a lot faster for me
listen I get tired uh running fences too
and uh they are a heck of a job so uh to
have somebody out there that I could
talk with this bottom line that he's
fiddling with pulling them out of the
dirt I'm not sure about five strand barb
wire with one just a couple inches off
the ground but I appreciate Gatlin glad
to help glad to have him working this
big boy right there that's a fence
wrecker everybody I have seen him come
through this fence after another bowl
and then when he knocked that bowl down
he sat on it to kill
it and uh d did out of all of its energy
he did as soon as he put his 2,000 plus
pounds on anyway that guy when he wants
to walk through a fence a fence doesn't
mean anything to him he just goes right
through it so he'll come through my lane
and then fight the bowl on that side so
the bowl on that side's a young one now
but it used to be an older one who ran
the show Romo was his name and he had
horns and I thought for sure this guy
wouldn't win he came through and whipped
old ROM
Mo I saw two out and I so I only brought
two Staples turned out that it was six
out so here I am had to walk back and
get
Staples said I don't need no more
practice walking I know how to do that
real
well that's what I did gave myself
practice
walking that's it young one we did
it next time you come out we'll do
another little bit that way we won't be
doing it all the you know they get tired
of that you sure you don't need a cowboy
hat
I want a cowboy up you don't want a
cowboy up huh huh you don't want a
cowboy up huh all
right well you got hair an old guy like
me and Sun just melts my bald little
head all right we're done right I mean
y'all come if I walk down this and pull
each strand I'd find wires missing I'll
do that after I fix everything out but
look how good much better that looks I
mean we had wires
crisscrossed over the top crap on the
rails man that looks so much better all
right let me get his
thoughts let's go we got to be able to
see our own face
yeah all right Gatlin what do you think
about fencing it's uh pretty easy what
it just takes a while it does take a
while it takes a while but it's not
difficult cool anyone can do it really
you know that old song desperado you've
been out riding fences for way too long
I just all right well that generational
Gap there but listen out riding fences
is a big deal imagine you were Cowboy at
King Ranch which is the size of Rhode
Island good Lord oh my God you every day
would be fence day yeah every day all
right well I'm going to wrap this thing
up we did uh let's see a little over um
I'm going to guess that's 3/10 so we did
a little over a half mile fence repair
I've got 1.2 miles around the outside
then I'm going to guess another couple
of miles going up and down so there's
plenty of fence to do between now and
Judgment Day all right like subscribe
follow us along I hope you learned a
little bit about fencing today
bye so I told Gatlin to go do a
three-point turn and he's never uh he's
never
driven youv so he doesn't even know what
that is uh go down that guy's driveway
pull in and back out